lori lightfoot this woman is just
absolutely awful there's no
other way to describe it she has
continued
the destruction of chicago can we find
out how many people were shot in chicago
this weekend we like to do that because
uh tons of people
are shot in chicago every weekend dozens
and dozens sometimes upwards of 100
people usually
about 10 or so deaths we'll get the
numbers in just a second oh you got the
numbers for me oh this is a good one
this is a good one damn we don't have
the uh the music for uh the deaths in
chicago yet we're working on that
play a little sort of game show music
when i talk about deaths in chicago
um 104 people were shot in chicago this
past weekend
19 dead uh i don't see any protests
anywhere
i don't see anyone demanding lori
lightfoot
step down i don't see anyone screaming
about racist
police so what let me think for a second
what could be going on here could it be
a people
that people of a certain color or people
are shooting at people of a certain
color and that doesn't fit the narrative
so we don't talk about that sort of
thing
i think that might be it uh all right so
we've got audio from
uh the new york times podcast of chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
doubling down on her insanely
racist decision to only be interviewed
by people of color take a listen back in
may mayor lightfoot announced that on
the occasion of the two-year anniversary
of her inauguration she would grant
one-on-one interviews exclusively to
journalists of color
she faced a lot of heat for it how do
you feel about
the the reaction to that um you're being
sued
some people including prominent
journalists of color called it a stunt
why did you tell me why you did that why
are you talking to me like i'm a white
lady
so here's the the bottom line for me
to state the obvious i'm a black woman
mayor i'm the mayor of the third largest
city in the country
obviously have a platform it's important
to me to advocate on things
that i believe are important and going
back to why i ran
to disrupt the status quo the media is
critically
important to our democracy you know this
better than i do the media is in a
time of incredible upheaval and
disruption
but our city hall press corps looks like
it's 1950 or 1970. when i look across
the podium
whether i'm in a formal press conference
or i'm out
in a neighborhood the reporters who show
up are invariably
overwhelmingly white intentionality
around diversity and inclusion is
crucial
people that make the hiring decisions
have to be focused
on diversity
modern racism ladies and gentlemen
brought to you by the tolerant
and diverse democratic party i want to
be very clear about this
nobody except these people nobody except
the woke progressives cares that she's
black nobody cares
she became mayor nobody cares nobody
cares that she's a woman
cares that she's a lesbo
she became mayor nobody cares she's a
black female lesbian mayor
nobody gives a flying except her
and her cohorts to use her identity
as a wedge issue to make the rest of us
feel racist
while she's the one who acts racist
that's what these people are and they
should be
ignored that's what they have to be they
have to be ignored
i don't even know why she was sitting
down with a white woman apparently this
interviewer was a white woman so i guess
she doesn't even believe the drivel that
she's putting out there
or she can put it aside if it's a
podcast as big as the new york times i
don't know that they have a big podcast
i don't know anyone that listens to new
york times or pays attention to the new
york times at this point but i suppose
they do or at least they fake numbers
like they fake numbers on their new york
times bestseller list
um but i guess she put it aside i will
sit with you
evil white devil to get my message out
about how you
people are the evil white devils